this video is brought to you by vessy
wow checking out these cool shoes i like
a shoe
that's a new one bessie makes everyday
sneakers that are comfortable stylish
and 100 waterproof you can walk in mud
or puddles and your feet will stay
completely dry i actually tried this
when i was in europe they're also 100
breathable so your feet won't stink oh
it smells good
so bessie sent me some shoes last year
and it was freaking awesome because i
was like
i'm gonna take it to my euro trip and i
put miles
or in their words kilometers uh
and we walked some mad distances and it
was super comfortable
and to me it's very difficult to find
water resistant
shoes that are also very light and
comfortable such as
these so i was really really happy that
we're working with them again
well you're not the only special one
because they also sent me shoes last
year too
and you know me if you tell me it's
waterproof i want to put it to the test
so i put them on
and i started hosing them down with my
garden hose and guess what my feet were
dry [ __ ] [ __ ] you
really did you swim with them too we
should go we should put these on
and just jump in your pool so that i i
tried that that doesn't work because the
water goes in from so it's
waterproof but the water can't go in
from another side oh okay that's
cheating that's like going
through the back right to prove this
water resistance
we're gonna get this dry tissue put it
in the shoe
and we're gonna pour water all over the
shoe
to show you oh my goodness look at this
it just rolls right off
oh yeah wow look at that
it don't even yeah unless you put the
water in here yeah but
should we do a test we put the tissue on
the outside and pour the water on the
inside yeah let's try that one
but this is working though okay okay so
here we go put the tissue outside
for the water
all right oh [ __ ] it holds it it hulk
then hold the water bottle
it doesn't come out good good job bessie
so it's waterproof any way you want
damn now that is dope it didn't even
soak through
nope it is 100 waterproof in your face
[ __ ] you to the haters vessi is having
this incredible
black friday sale right now so grab
yourself a pair before they run out of
your size and if you missed the sale you
could use our code jkn to get 25
off your vesti shoes go to the link in
the description below to get the code
and link
i'm walking here keep your feet dry with
vessie
100 scientifically proven here in your
face
mama [ __ ] you i'm knocking boots
oh [ __ ] you could jizz on them too
[Music]
back in the beginning of quarantine we
all had a curfew
right how did you guys feel about the
curfew
oh i don't even remember wait wow that
was terrified i was like the world is
dangerous
i do remember now yeah
oh you know what was [ __ ] up about
that they told english speakers one time
like one uh yeah curfew time
and then it was like a four hour like
heads up and then for the spanish
speaker
text messages oh that's funny it was
like a one hour heads up and it was a
different like one hour after some [ __ ]
i forgot what it was exactly but it was
[ __ ] up they were in a different time
zone
they gave them a different time it took
them three hours to translate
they're like they couldn't find
well and so in europe right now it seems
like they're
all closing back down again like i know
england
uh uk it's flu season they're closing
down again germany for a whole month
paris i think is also close paris that's
right or france in general france uh and
then the country of paris
yes it's true and czech republic is also
required to shut down and their time is
actually one hour before us so it's 9
p.m for them
so they have a very early curfew that's
crazy because the czech republic
son of mom what happened there what
happened you used some of the fake money
to clean this up
the czech republic was like one of the
best success stories of europe
and then they were the first to get it
under control
they were the first to uh like what do
you call it lockdown quarantine
and then um basically everyone's like oh
you got to be like a czech republican
and then they uh they were the first two
kind of shots
open up and stuff but then i heard it oh
my ears are the ones that pick it up
and now this is what happened now
they're having a problem
it seems like the world is never going
to relax
is there a country that like what curb
the the coronavirus and then never
got one taiwan taiwan taiwan they don't
land nobody
i feel like island countries hat it's
easy
because it's like don't come here well
they've already been doing the mask
thing and they're more they do
trust their government and they do
listen they were on top of it they're
way more obedient
than australia like back to normal i had
no idea the last i heard they went on
lockdown again again
you can't even go to different uh states
i heard so like
i was like because i thought they were
creating their bubble with new zealand
i don't well what i recently asked my
friend australia
is he was like yeah we can't australia
that's tight his name is honestly my
friend
in australia my friend australia
australia jones yeah it's all fantastic
from australia and your name is
australia
but no they they can't go interstate
there
they have to stay in their i don't know
what it's called territory or providence
or whatever
province yeah providence province
province i don't know i don't know
providence road some british [ __ ] right
yeah territory yeah cause they started
like a turf
hey
like uh some sports event or some [ __ ]
and everyone was like
normal times no one's wearing a mask it
didn't seem like anyone was social
distancing it just looked like normal
maybe it's new zealand
maybe yeah because i heard new zealand
is like everything is normal
and you know their leader is a female
[ __ ] same in taiwan damn
oh look at that name in germany
all right we'll move over by then and
then camilla harris move on in
huh germany has a big case yeah oh
really all right nick why'd you set me
up like that dude i don't know i don't
know about germany
germany oh tiff why'd you set me up like
i'm just saying she's a people leader
so the goal is to put women in charge
and coronavirus will disappear well
everything is neat and organized
and orderly it didn't just a few other
things will probably disappear
i mean i mean like if if we could if we
could
just look at the different gender
bathrooms and go yeah if you can
organize the country
like the the bathroom then i i would
trust women a lead
definitely have you guys ever been
anything that you'll trust women we
probably need women to leave for like a
good dynasty
you know what i mean the whole planet
how long is that dynasty what really but
that happened in china it didn't really
work out did it how well you
there was a female leader in china
empress dodge or something the last one
yeah named after that empress dodgers
i don't know anyways in czech republic
they have a curfew 9 p.m
and i'm not sure what all their uh like
uh
regulations are in terms of what they
can't do or like at least
all the reasons why they're allowed to
go out past uh 9 pm so it seems like
if you have a medical emergency or you
have whatever
you can go out past 9 9pm but other than
that you can't right
so one of the things that people can
actually leave
past leave their homes past 9 pm is to
walk their dog
but not everyone has a dog
so the one person in particular walked
through iguana then
uh no he didn't yes guess what he walked
teddy bear
a badger teddy bear is pretty close
this is what the cops found when they
come what is that
in the czech republic oh a stuffed dog
oh it's a fake thing
this is the guy walking the dog and this
is his dog so it looks like he was just
dragging it
he's just dragging on the sled that's
hilarious on a sled
yeah that's [ __ ] hilarious dude
so it's like on the sled
yeah i commend him one more did he get
in trouble
uh he uh he got a warning yeah see that
you got a warning well done actually a
lot of people are pissed off about that
because like people are like
in italy you would have been uh you know
taken to prison or you would have gotten
a ticket or whatever
this guy got away from this right like
you have to give a for effort
maybe they gotta take it super serious
over there because it's like why do you
get special privileges but also though
and everyone will be loopholing it why
does he have to be out of his house that
later exactly
he just wanted to go out you guys he
didn't have a
so let me let me uh let me read to you
what he said
he doesn't have a backyard i think it's
funny it is pretty [ __ ] like totally
i'll be like honestly if i was the cop
right i'd be like all right that's
that's all right warning don't do this
again but
that's good would you be holding your
laugh in yeah
are you kidding that's why we have
pictures it's probably because the cops
had to take multiple
pictures yeah it is funny but but it's
also like really entitled of him too
it's like
i can go out just because i want like
it's just weird well no you're taking a
chance
one time and if you get your warning
then you should i think the the
stupidity of it though
is he thought he was going to get away
with this like how much work he put on
he put into doing this like this is
that's what bothers me
he had the tie well he went he had to
buy a full-size stuffed animal
but he other things with your time
right true but it's his mental health
dude he needed to get out
start smoking or something maybe that
would be like a good way they allow
smoke breaks
maybe he was smoking and that's he was
like huh
like cigarettes you know you get the
wrong dog yeah yeah that's what it is
this isn't just
shrooming out and he's just [ __ ] yeah
so then he said
when confronted by the police he said
i'm not i'm walking a dog here i'm not
doing anything illegal
see that that's annoying first that was
his first response he needs to go to
jail for that
bro are you drunk uh they didn't say
whether or not he was drunk or on any
sort of substance
and then when the police demanded an id
from him he then said
oh you know what it's an artistic uh
practical joke and that was his name
oh my god he should get his ass kicked
now
yeah that's annoying bro imagine you're
a cop and you're working and you have to
go tell this [ __ ] guy that has a
stuffed animal on a sled like
dude you have to go back to your house
imagine you're a performing artist and
then you you hear this
like appropriating your your occupation
exactly true imagine you're a dog and
you're like
roof didn't i was gonna go there did you
didn't i was going to go there he
laughed at everything i like him
casey is the most supportive guy yeah
he's great yeah
that guy they shouldn't just throw him
in jail for like 15 minutes they should
show his attitude he's too much of a
[ __ ] smart house yeah that's that's
annoying like don't be so [ __ ] cute
with it dude get out of here
like because if i if i got copy like off
but
you're right i'm like sorry i can't go
home you're just like
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i thought i
could get away with it i'm sorry
but if you egg on the cop like he's a
dumb ass then it's like all right what
are you doing here this guy is
his job you're at his job right now and
you're [ __ ] it up yeah it's annoying
super annoying yeah so then the cop said
i never liked it
uh so the cops the cops in the end let
him off with the warning so
no no real punishment here and then they
said uh
uh this really unusual case was finally
resolved by the police by agreement
this is bad oh this crazy case so they
had to like
it's three songs that's how safe the
czech republic is
yeah and they said the young man
listened to the patrol warning and then
went home
he regretted his actions like cool the
fact like okay sure
so yeah so then you know uh neighboring
countries like italy and stuff
you know they they kind of like were
upset about the fact that this guy got
led off so easily where
in their own countries it's not it's not
gonna go the next day go to the pet shop
and be like all right just give me
whatever
pet oh my god like not even taking care
of this new animal just because he wants
to go at it
before he actually walks to the isle of
cops like this [ __ ] again shoots the
fake animal it's actually real
oh no that's dark why would you say
[Laughter]
support that casey that's like kind of
crazy yeah dude
what if he was walking a pair do you
think they would let him would the
parrot walk walker like
they'll wobble fly fly at the leash
level sometimes birds like to look
at the leash level that's kind of cool
it just kind of hovers
yeah and then you'll be tight yeah it
would be cool
yeah like you think if you if you had a
living dream
if you had a living thing the cops were
just like well it's not a dog
but all right you're walking no if i was
a cop i don't want i
better be a [ __ ] dog what about a cat
maybe a cat
dude you're what if it's you're one of
those cops you're like one of those like
to the books kind of cops huh yep that's
me
what made what makes a dog life better
than the cat life
well because cats are neater and they
they like to do it in a box like they
have their restrooms set up but dogs are
just [ __ ] savages oh so they need
that walk
exactly yeah but what about a komodo
dragon yeah
a komodo dragon yeah what's your answer
about yeah they need to move
they get cold they don't got fur you
know how cold the czech republic is
once you wrap them up in that that igloo
sweater then they think that it's a
child crawling on the floor
on the floor and they're just like what
the [ __ ] child protective services
and then they shoot it because that's
what they would do
look casey
gets a perm suddenly kills everything
what about a pig you're walking
a pig how about that i think that's fair
game they need exercise but they also
don't survive in the colds
like what is it casey shoot them oh my
god casey
casey's like i want park i want barbecue
we're going to shoot
i want some sandwich chinese barbecue
now
jump ship when the czech republic was
sam woo
they got chinese food out there there's
chinese food everywhere and his dad has
always find it that's true i got it i
got it what if we're walking
a deer they're made for the cold and
people get
ticks everywhere right is that what is
that what they do yeah like a deer
spread ticks then you could do a
reindeer like a bambi or like you can
walk a deer
deers are mad skittish though you know
you're not going to be not if it's
domesticated
you're right you're right you
domesticated a deer
this guy's good i can't compete dude i
gotta find
a way to walk something that's not a dog
who's that guy on instagram that pets
all the deer and stuff what's up
that guy the guy that got john santa
your brother
yeah he's like puerto rican or something
isn't he yeah he got jumped he got
jumped yeah i don't know what he did
your story back because they were
jealous that he was hot
yeah cause he got all diva on them yeah
oh [ __ ] he was drunk
the influencer was a very different one
but that i think that ruined him didn't
it yeah apparently he's nicer to animals
than he is to people
which most animal people are sure what's
up with that
[Music]